-So, this is a great documentary
about sort of the '90s
and Bad Boy Records.
But it also --
kind of what brings it together
is you had a 20th reunion
concert with everybody.
-Yes. Yes.
-Was that nerve-racking?
Was that exciting?
How did you feel in the time
leading up to that concert?
Because that was --
We saw you sort of talking about
the lights you wanted
with your staff.
-Yeah. It was --
-Did you get the lights
you wanted?
Did you get the God light?
-Yeah. Yeah.
I got the God light.
[ Laughter ]
But it really was
like a family reunion,
when you don't know what's going
to happen at a family reunion,
and there's some unresolved
issues with a lot of the family.
-Yeah.
-So we started it out as like,
just a concert documentary,
but when we got together,
we had to deal with the issues
about career and our lives
and things that we haven't
dealt with together.
And it really -- just really
showed the story of
our evolution, and our ups and
downs, trials and tribulations,
life, death, and overall
at the end of the day,
victory for us all
being together
on one stage at one time.
-It was really wonderful.
You talk about life and death,
which is of course one of the
parts of this story.
Biggie kind of hangs over
the story of Bad Boy Records.
-Yes.
-It seems like that's something
you reflect on every day.
-Yes.
-Was it helpful to reflect on it
with everybody from that era?
-Yeah, it was definitely helpful
to reflect on it with everybody
that was in the Bad Boy family
and on the label
because we all were traumatized
by it.
But it wasn't just us.
It was our fans,
and it was
the people of Brooklyn.
So us all being able to come
back together on his birthday
and have this concert,
it kind of gave us some closure
and we were able to kind of
put it behind us
and celebrate his life.
-It was really great.
You did two nights.
You felt better about
the second night.
-Yes, yes.
-Was this just sort of athletes
who maybe needed to get back
into the groove?
Is that what you felt like?
-Yeah, I mean,
I'm a perfectionist,
and most people that came to
the first show,
they really loved
but I knew that the things
that went wrong,
and that's always been the thing
about me,
is that I'm very, very hard
on myself,
and the first show was like --
The next morning I was crying,
and my kids --
I told my kids I needed to come
up to the hotel room
because I just needed somebody
to cry in front of
because I was so disappointed.
I was like a kid
in Little League.
You know what I'm saying?
So I'm kind of, like, spoiled
with the performances --
-Wait. You called your children
because you wanted to cry
in front of them?
-Yeah. I mean --
-That seems like it would be
very traumatic for them.
-Yeah, yeah.
But I was crying alone,
and I felt lonely --
-Yeah, there we go.
[ Laughter ]
-I needed somebody to tell me
it was going to be all right.
-You do plenty for them.
You do plenty for them.
-Exactly.
-It's about time they do
something for you.
-It was the first time
they saw it,
and I just, you know,
I was in a desperate situation,
and I called my family --
-There you go.
-And I was like,
"I'm up here crying.
Y'all need to get up here."
[ Laughter ]
But the second night --
The second night really --
I mean, you really got to go
see the movie.
"Can't Stop Won't Stop."
It's in theaters
just up till this week.
We did a limited run,
but you can go to Apple Music,
and you can get it there.
And it will also be on iTunes
July 7th.